عندما أقول حرية
[تصفيق]
فلسطين ليست ضد
أي أحد، فهذا يعني في الواقع أنه يجب علينا
حماية
الجميع، ويعني المساواة للجميع،
واحترام السلام والحب،
ويعني الحق في الوجود
بغض النظر عن القطاع الذي تنتمي إليه، ونيتي هي
عدم الإساءة إلى
أي شخص أبدًا.  أريد أن تشعر كل روح في هذه الساحة
بانعكاس
الحب ولكن هناك بشر أبرياء في
غزة يُقتلون بدولاراتنا
وتلك الأرواح البشرية الثمينة هي
امتداد لنا.
لا أستطيع الوقوف هنا مرتديًا معطفًا من الفرو
وأقفز وأتظاهر بينما  في
أحشائي، حدسي يقول أنك تعرف بشكل أفضل، بن
الأسلاف يصرخون من الأفضل أن تتقدم
من
أجلنا. أحب إخوتي وأخواتي اليهود
كثيرًا ووجهة نظري واحدة
تقول أن فلسطين الحرة متجذرة أيضًا في
حمايتك يا
أحبائي.